hello teachers i'm sal khan founder of
the not for profit khan academy and i'm
here to announce a nationwide back to
school learning challenge called learn
storm
learnstorm is an exciting way to jump
start your school year around learning
activities it's designed to motivate
your students and to help build their
growth mindset this year was amazing
with learnstorm i had a group of
students that couldn't add subtract
multiply or divide fractions they
avoided it at all costs but since it was
an assignment they would try it and they
would eventually do much better and what
was amazing was that the lower achieving
students were able to see that they were
part of something
huge they were able to contribute and
that i thought boosted their
self-confidence their self-esteem and i
didn't realize that would happen after
doing learnstorm
[Music]
learnstorm is a good way to
differentiate
and as well as motivate
and with the growth mindset pieces you
can also educate them about
why it's important to learn how they
learn how their body is set up to learn
what strategies help them learn it's
amazing it's amazing and it's free
we think this is really going to
motivate your students to understand to
appreciate that they truly can learn
anything the activities have been
designed to have measurable gains in
learning attitudes one thing i learned
from the growth mindset activities is
that your intelligence can grow just
like your muscles can grow and that's
something that really stuck with me
because i didn't know that before
i did over 300 lessons in one week i
felt proud of myself getting all these
good grades it helps the students
tremendously their confidence is higher
they're able to do it and it warms my
heart that they think that way now and
they know that they can keep going and
keep growing and nothing will stand in
their way
so together as we jump start this school
year i look forward for all of us living
the learnstorm motto to keep going and
to keep growing